[Applause]
very nice to meet you thanks for coming
i always watch this in such amazement
watch what a tv very hard job that you
have what this job piece of cake
talk terrible very hard they put these
clothes on us andy and i come out here
babble for an hour and the checks keep
coming
so modest but you're very charming oh
thank you very much not a legitimate
staring contest
why you're an irish catholic boy that's
right and i'm an irish catholic girl
i'm one of eight how many siblings what
how many siblings uh there are six kids
in my family
and i have eight we grew up for high
stakes and played that game no gags in
the background
really you guys put 100 bill on this
table right now
really i would give you a two minute
time limit and i would win
well
wait a minute andy can do anything he
wants anybody from the audience can do
anything they want
anything for two minutes really i will
win won't this sort of hurt the talking
segment
it might be a little detrimental but
that could be a class
oh okay well do you have a hundred bucks
on you i'm gonna could you lend me a
hundred and i'd be walking away
no way forget it i don't have a hundred
dollars
i said the checks keep coming but
they're not big checks
i got like 18 dollars a week yeah
you're well dressed for it thank you
this is one piece it zips up the back
now you know what kathleen turner said
uh
that what an interesting woman she is
she's a fascinating woman and she said
actually during the commercial break she
said i'd love to stick around because
she had to run
should i want to stick around because i
want to do a whose voice is lower
with kate mulgrew she said that actually
she said speaking like this her voice is
considerably lower but you have a great
voice too you have a fantasy my voice
has been the subject of much controversy
this year and i'm not kidding
what do you mean controversy a lot of
people uh were very concerned about my
voice possibly as the
the captain now it's resonating in a
very peculiar way that's an echo in this
chamber
what do you mean people like fans i have
men i think what do they
they printed in they punch it into the
internet said she sounds like a cross
between a munchkin
and a sort of catherine hepburn on speed
really people on the internet said that
some guy
on the internet those vicious nerds how
could they do that to you
thank you yeah really and you don't but
you don't take that personally you
you know you [ __ ] your head well i try
not to take that dude can you imagine
okay
oh it hurts with the commands i guess
yeah
sort of a full speed ahead let's go
we're powered
and the bund is now either let me tell
you
scotty give me more power i know there's
no scotty on your show no more scouting
god bless his soul uh now what makes you
qualified though while we're on the
subject what makes you qualified to be
a a starship captain then i think it
harkens back to my youth
i was the oldest the oldest you were the
oldest of eight the oldest girl the
second oldest of eight
bossy a surrogate mother i had to do a
lot for my mother
she used to make me run in and check all
the cribs to see if they were breathing
that's a fun chore it was great and
that's basically what i do on the ship
check on everyone see their breathing i
think it's just an inherent
question really well that's interesting
you think birth order is that important
because i'm the middle of six
somebody told me yeah i was the middle
child fighting for attention
screaming for love the only way i could
get it was to get my own tv show
constantly is this freaking people out
uh
but uh but but it's interesting birth
order they say is very important and you
were the oldest which means that you
were in charge
yeah i think we're empowered but we're
also probably i'm sorry this microphone
is right in the middle of my where is
your microphone
that's um
i was empowered by my mother but i think
you also get a little demented about the
whole thing
eight children is a lot of children that
doesn't happen anymore i mean
it used to irish catholic families nine
kids
12 kids i knew a family that lived not
too far from my family
they had like 14 kids the duckies were
16 the o'rourke's were 18 it was nothing
i know kids were like meeting each other
for the first time you know brothers and
sisters
we're like getting together at the
bathroom it was crazy there's only four
of us
see he's you're german though right yeah
german swedish german swedish
very very smart yeah my folks didn't get
along much anyway they
had separate uh welcome to late night
therapy everybody
there's a couch right here we'll get
started this is helpful
i don't know what i think about the
large family i'm proud to be a member of
it but it's gone it's not gonna happen
anymore i'm not gonna meet a woman who's
gonna have a leverage
lately they're still doing it in ireland
they're still having 11 15.
doing something yes you're still doing
something oh i guess i spent the summer
there last year and nothing changes
really i am always fascinated i say
you're such strict roman catholics which
i applaud and i admire
and yet there must be a great deal of
sexual activity
i think when you there are 18 kids yes
something's going on yeah nothing is
definitely wrong i mean i'm no scientist
they won't discuss it and they get very
incentive oh no no catholics can't wait
to talk to you about that there
no that's not right catholics can't talk
about sex i have women all the time come
on the show and they start to talk about
sex and they're coming on to me it's an
occupational hazard
and uh i can't handle it it's happened
once
okay it never happened are you married
anyway huh no i'm not married do you
have a girlfriend yes i do
is it good yes i am very happy with my
girlfriend
is what good your relationship with your
girlfriend oh yeah i think some people
misinterpreted when you said is it good
i think so nobody misinterpreted it yeah
there was a guy
there was a guy who was thinking i think
somebody misinterpreted i thought would
you say you're in love
oh no it's not tall i will not talk
about my private life on the show i'm
irish catholic i can't do it but now
he's gonna
turn it yeah let's talk about your
personal life are you in love
i am in love yeah really that's good for
you who is this person he's good for me
uh he's a bit of an enigma you see me
i'm getting a little nervous about you
you see it's not
easy yes it's hard it's hard because i'm
old
you're not old i'm too old really to
discuss my private life you're not
when i was younger i was much freer
about it oh i'm happy
i'm happier than i've ever been before
that's very nice that's a very nice
thing and it is a contributing factor a
large contributing factor oh well that's
a nice thing to be able to say
yeah but i think lovely i think it would
be a funny hallmark card i'm very happy
and you are a large contributing factor
you know and i wrote they have them
if they don't have it now they should
have it uh now i i heard that you
were on the subject of irish and and
irish people and irish culture and irish
lore that you can do an irish jig is
that true
oh please frank smiley will i
frank smiley's been berating me better
frank smiley i should explain to people
at home as an idiot who works on our
show
and uh his job
he's right over there there he is
[Applause]
anyway frank's job is to badger is to
badger the talent to the guests that
come on the show into doing things they
don't want to do and make them miserable
is that well i thought it was pretty
remarkable we had a 45-minute
conversation
this is a pre-interview right you know
what i love you know what i love is this
is what frank tells me
uh oh yeah she wants to do the jig go
ahead i know you did too frank didn't
you
frank he'll never work again no he
didn't say that in fairness
in fairness to friends needed me at the
door with the kaylee shoes he says the
band's got the jig you got to do it you
got it
you don't know no no no no no he didn't
say that in fairness frank smiley said
to me
she's not sure about doing the jig you
could try and coax her into doing the
jig and the audience can hoot and cheer
and there'll be this incredible pressure
okay there you go all right all right
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute we
have a policy on this show though
it's only fair if the guest won't do the
jig i will do the jig oh good
it's no good i know it's gonna it's
gonna be crappy but max just i'll do the
jig kate mogrew doesn't have to do it
and that way uh
other talented people watching right now
won't be afraid to come on the show
come on join me at least
come on is that how you do it
that's very good
hands down was my jig so bad
let's take a break we'll be right back
with the suits we'll see in a second